le 27 mai approche à grands pas et pour
fêter ma moment j'ai décidé de lui
offrir des fleurs mais pas n'importe
lesquels des fleurs en papier et
aujourd'hui on va faire le modèle rouge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ont commencé on va prendre le pot de
yaourt un peu de peinture
[Applaudissements]
ensuite on va faire la tige bien sûr
alors moi ce sont des grands bâtons en
bois donc prendre plus humbles je prends
la tête du pôle voudrais que ça dépasse
légèrement
[Musique]
ensuite le papier crépon donc bien sûr
moi j'ai décidé de faire des fleurs
rouges ou des coupes une petite bande
on va faire des arrondis sur le papier
qui va nous permettre de faire des
pétales
ensuite je prends mon petit bateau un
petit bout de scotch qui va me permettre
de faire tenir la base de ma fleur et là
il va fort que gens roulent mais en
fronçant légèrement pour permettre de
former ma fleur
j'ai fini de faire ma fleur il faut bien
sûr le faire tenir rien de plus simple
un petit les coûts de scotch
[Musique]
on le fait on le scotch à la base
légèrement en biais en enroulant
descendant jusqu'au bout de la tige
je n'ai plus qu'à la mettre dans le pot
de fleurs et d'en faire de plus en plus
pour faire un peu comme ça moi j'en ai
fait une autre un peu plus gros se
trouve plein de modèles sur internet
n'hésitez pas à vous taper fleurs en
papier crépon
voilà moi j'ai pour offrir ça à ma maman
et vous camille qu'est ce que vous allez
faire